so it's been three days since the m2
macbook pro came out and we have done a
ton of tests and comparisons and put out
multiple videos in this one i want to
give you guys a short video about the
good the bad and the outright ugly about
this laptop and my perspective for real
world use with this laptop instead of
just benchmarks now the first thing for
a positive that i want to talk about is
the webcam now a lot of people have
really hated on apple for sticking with
the 720p webcam and i agree they should
have put a 1080p in but it does look
better now the weird thing is is that
it's only better because of software
they tweaked the algorithm for the noise
reduction they added better contrast or
else that's what it looks like now with
that the 14 inch and 16 inch and even
the upcoming m2 macbook air are still
going to look more detailed sharper less
noise
but at least they've done the software
fix which they should do to the previous
ones to make it look a little bit better
now the second thing that i noticed is
the speakers now in my comparison
against the m1 macbook pro i said that
they sound about the same i couldn't
hear much of a difference but then some
of you guys called it out and said that
no in fact the m1 has better dynamics it
sounds better and the truth is when we
were listening i told him that i thought
that the bass was better on the m1 and
it sounded slightly louder it just
didn't make sense why that would happen
and because i was unsure i was just
leaving it up to you guys but you guys
spoke and with that when we monitored in
final cut it did show about a two
decibels louder kind of volume on the m1
model so i don't know why the m2 doesn't
sound as good the m1 already was the
worst sounding macbook out of the full
lineup so that is definitely unfortunate
now the next thing is the fan
now this thing when you're using it day
to day
it almost seems like a macbook air that
is fanless
you don't hear it unless you're doing
heavy rendering for a very long time and
i'm not talking about running a couple
runs of cinebench it still is silent
apple let this thing heat up the most we
recorded is 104 on screen but actually
hit 105
and they didn't care the fans only
barely started to ram up ramp up there
so they're treating it more like a
macbook air instead of a pro whereas the
m1 pro even though it uses less power
and less wattage and has less heat the
fans actually ramp up quicker now that
is a positive if you don't want to hear
the fans day to day if you have a
previous intel model and you're annoyed
of it well this is going to be way
better it's a great experience not
hearing that fan but for those of you
guys that are concerned about the high
heat
that the chip gets and how hot it gets
well you could download tg fan pro and
you can change the settings yourself to
have it spin up a little bit earlier
yeah you don't have to make it be crazy
loud but at least spin up if it's
hitting 100 degrees now one thing i
really wish this thing had was fast
charging we've been testing these things
running down the batteries and it takes
forever to charge it up closer to three
hours whereas the rest of the lineup now
as far as charging 50
in just 30 minutes and so that when you
do have to charge that is an
inconvenience but flipping over to the
battery life it is
incredible for light uses
better than the m1 macbook pro which is
already amazing now dave lee actually
did some very in-depth testing he has
this chart so i'm not going to make my
own i'll show you his thank you dave and
this thing for light uses is shockingly
good and it works really good because it
has the larger more powerful efficiency
cores that apple updated so it doesn't
have to use the performance cores as
much but on the flip side if you are
going to start pushing it that is when
the battery life does get worse than it
was before because it is using roughly
33 percent more power in order to gain
about 13 more performance on the cpu and
then the graphics also uses more power
as well and of course we already
mentioned ssds in multiple videos we
made a video specifically about that
performance
and this is just something that is very
sad that this is happening now i know
apple needs to make money maybe there's
not enough chip supply and so they're
trying to do a single chip instead of
two but it's just weird having a product
that came out a year and a half later
that is an expensive product with the
pro name on it but the ssd is half the
speed compared to before now we already
mentioned that what i didn't mention is
slc caching now when you're transferring
a large file most of these ssds
they will actually slow down after a
certain amount is written and what i
found is that with the
256 gig model on the m2 it actually
slows down earlier so about 40 45 gigs
and then it slows down from about 1 300
megabytes per second
all the way down to about an average of
200 250 now the m1 also the base model
256 gig it will actually record right at
uh 1900 from my external ssd and it also
does slow down takes a little bit longer
but then when it slows down it's still
riding over 400 so i actually
transferred a big file which is our test
folder with a bunch of different
benchmarks the m2 took 5 minutes and 34
seconds while the m1 took 2 minutes and
55 seconds and keep in mind it actually
would have been quite a bit faster if we
had a faster external ssd this one is
just our favorite because it's universal
it's a great price
so that is unfortunate because not only
will it slow down even more with the soc
cash but also if you guys didn't see our
ssd test video with real world tests
when you're opening up professional
applications a bunch of tabs it is less
responsive than the macbook and i wanted
to do that test just to see
um
was i right was this actually less
snappy and in fact it is and
professional uses also slow down if
you're loading up the same amount of
tabs and applications on the m1 versus
m2 the m2 gets slower which is insane
and that just brings me to you know my
kind of thoughts on this machine it
should not be called pro in 2022
now if this came out at the time that m1
did it still have been a great update
compared to the intel model but we're
taking one step back the ssds can't keep
up with most of these thunderbolt drives
now the whole system slows down if you
open up multiple applications
so if you do want to have a laptop for
light simple tasks you're going to get
insane battery life
it's going to work well
but that means it's not a pro machine so
that is just the weird thing about it
now we're gonna do some more testing
we're gonna look at video editing um
some more in-depth stuff so make sure
you guys are gonna watch that if you
guys want more info
but for your guys's questions people are
asking should i jump to the 16 gig model
or 512 because we're now not
recommending the base model because the
ssds are slow and the whole system slows
down
well it depends on how much uh space you
need for example if you don't use more
than 256 gig like i do jump up to 16 gig
if you want to have more space well then
that speed is gonna kick back up to the
level of the m1 at the base even though
you have to spend 200 bucks more and
that makes it a much more responsive
system when you're using it so i would
uh i would end up
getting more storage if you feel like
you might need it but if not kick up the
ram and then the hard thing is if you
kick both up well at that point you're
not far off from the 14 inch which is
our next comparison and you can buy one
of those for 200 bucks off right now on
amazon so 100 bucks more than the m2
that is crazy i will link that down
below now about the m2 macbook air
they're asking will the m2 macbook air
ssds
we will see i sure hope not but i think
if apple is doing this to their pro
machine i would expect the m2 macbook
air to also get slower
compared to the previous generation and
the last question we're getting is
should you just buy an m1 refurbished or
used or a discount compared to getting
the m2 model well if you're getting a
good price on it i think yes especially
if you want to get the base model
because
you are going to have a snappy system
when you open up a bunch of tabs or
programs it's still going to stay
quicker than if you would have had an m2
at that base configuration
and even though the cpu is faster on the
m2 it's not a huge difference you're
still going to be very happy with the m1
and then if you don't use the graphics
you're not constantly pushing it that
part will matter to you at all so if
you're getting a nice discount and of
course amazon has great deals they're
clearing these out now i think you'll be
happy with it or the m1 macbook air
which was our favorite laptop or until
the m21 comes out so there you guys go
if you have any other questions you want
us to cover in our full review after
we've done more testing go ahead and ask
down below click above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there that's been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]